動詞のルール
に関する最新のビデオをリリースした後、多く
の人が
同じような 3 つの質問をするように
なりました。
カットせずにやってみようと思います。
これ
は即興の日本語
発音の高低アクセントのレクチャーになると
思います。一部の人たちの助けになることを願っています。
この最新のビデオで、
特に日本語の動詞動詞は
常にアクセントを持ち、この
アクセントは常に単語の最後から 2 番目のビートで発生し、
この例は成長する単語であると述べまし
た。 アクセントとアクセントは、単語の
最後から 2 番目のビートで
発生してい
ます。アクセントは、津の前の音で発生して
いる
ので
、実際の質問の種類は、
これが動詞 b で発生することを理解しています。
ut
で終わる日本語のすべての単語で
同じこと
が起こって
いるように感じます
そのアクセントは
、
これが本当なのか、それとも私が
聞いているだけなのか、これに対する短い答え
は、これは真実ではなく
、ケースバイケースの基本的なことですが、
私が望む非常に重要なことです.
ここで強調しておきたいのは、
動詞のルールは動詞に特化
したものであり、最終的に何が起こったの
か、なぜ多くの人
が名詞で同じことが起こると聞いていると言っているのかと
思います.これ
はあなたの耳が遊んでいる完璧な例だと思います.
あなたがまだピッチアクセントを学んでいるなら、あなたにトリックがあり
ますあなたが英語のネイティブスピーカーなら、utzを聞くのは簡単です.
そして、
無意識のうち
に靴の単語を見
たり、日本語のスピーカーが言うのを聞いたりするかもしれません.
この言葉
を聞いたら、彼らがそれを言って、
パターンを理解するために心を本当に訓練していない場合は
、たとえ彼らがそれを1つの方法で言ったとしても、
あなたはほとんど
文字通り彼らを聞く
でしょう.
だまされて
、違う言い方をされているのを聞くと
、日本人が言ったと思って、実際は日本人が
言っていることな
のに、そのように言うことになります。
low high low どちらか
ではなく どちらが正しいか
high low low
アクセントが単語の最後に来る日本語のこのパターン
これはオダカ単語の最後のアクセント パターンとして知られており、これ
が最も
難しいパターンだと思います 英語のネイティブ
スピーカーが拾い上げて再現
するのは、これが
理由で、
非常に多くの英語のネイティブスピーカーが繰り返しますが、
私はこれを試み
ていません。この間違いをすることを恥ずかしく思う必要はありません。
私は同じ
間違いを何度も
犯しました。 間違いだ
けど始めたら 日本語を
学ぶと、弟や妹を意味する言葉を学びます。
この
ようにつづります。妹はこのようにつづります。
圧倒的多数の英語ネイティブ スピーカーは、
日本語を学び始める
と、これを「imo」ではなく「imo」と言うでしょう。
もしあなたが英語のネイティブ
スピーカーなら
、アクセントが単語の最後に来るアクセントパターンを言うのは本当に難しいからです.
同じ種類のもの
は英語には実際には存在しないので、
私たちは. 基本的に
四角形の穴に円を当てはめようとしている
それが正しい表現であれば、それは一種の
状況であり、計算されない 計算しきれません 私は
ただこのように言って
しまいます これはすべて無意識のうちに起こっている これ
が人々がむしろくつがと言う理由です
これよりは、人々が「いもとが」ではなく「いもとが」と言う理由です。
人々
が靴のような言葉をklutzgaと言って
いるのを聞いていると思うなら、それはほぼ間違いなく、
日本人が言うのを聞くのは簡単だから
です。
同じファミリーに属さない他の言葉でそれが
起こっていると仮定すると、接続されるべきではない方法でドットを接続するのは
危険です. おそらく発生する可能性がありますが
、明確なルールでは
ないので
、最初の質問に答えてくれることを願っています。
私はセールスマンのようになりたくないので
、常に製品をプラグインしています
が、
おそらく私が受けた2番目に一般的な質問
です
おそらく 50 人だけ
がビデオの最後まで見ていたので、大丈夫でした。
この給料について詳しく知るにはどうすればよいでしょうか。
これについては良い本がたくさんありますが、私の
個人的な経験
では、これらの本から最大限の利益を得るには、最初からかなり高いレベルの日本語か、比較的高い言語学の理解が必要です。
私が試みているのは
、パトレオンで高低アクセントを教えようとしているので、もし
あなたが
高低アクセントについてもっと学び
たいと思っていて、おそらく日本語の勉強を始めたばかりで、
あまり知らないなら、
私は作成しようとしました.
私が日本語を勉強していたときに欲しかったリソースです.日本語を勉強していたときに
ピッチアクセントを学ぶためにこれらの本をたくさん手に入れましたが、
それらはすべて日本語で書かれていたか、再び日本語だったので、彼らが何を言っているのか理解できません
でした.
大学院生
や言語学の学生向けのようなものなので
、まったくの初心者にピッチアクセントを
非常にシンプルで明確で
理解しやすい英語で教えるリソースを作成しようとしましたが、それは
良い製品です。また、
できるだけネイティブに聞こえるようにし
たい場合
は、恥知らずなプラグであるpatreon.comの下のリンクでチェックすることをお勧めします
が、私は自分が作成した製品を誇りに思っており、
そう思います 安価で高低アクセント
を学習するためのおそらく最良のリソース
だと
思います.今すぐ自分の製品について話すの
をやめて、次の質問に進みます.
次の質問は
、日本人と日本語を話しているときによくあります.  「
自分が何を言っているのか理解
できず、どこでミスをしているのかわからないので、イライラしています。
これがピッチ事故のミスなの
か、それとも発音のミスなのかわかりません。
なぜ彼らが私の言っていることを理解できないのかわかりません
が、あなたのビデオ
では、あなたのピッチ事故が間違っていたとしても、
人々はあなたの言っていることを理解するだろう
と言っていました。
これは素晴らしい質問だと何度も言っています
ここで起こっていることは
また、日本語の教室
で、日本語の
発音は非常に単純であると教えられることがよく
あります。このため、日本語の発音
は通常、表面レベルでしか教えられて
いません。
私の大学の日本語のコースでは、
高低アクセントについて何も学びませんでした。
これについてもっと学ぶ
ために、自分で調べなければなりませんでした。
あなたのスピーチには小さな間違いがあります。
繰り返しますが、うーんと言う
と、
人々はあなたの
言っていることを理解するでしょ
う。 ただし
、これらは両方ともこれらの
単語だけを単独で言っていました。
多くの単語を続けて言うと
、これらの単語の複数の多くが正しくありません ect
ピッチ アクセント パターンが
過剰になると
、
英語のネイティブ スピーカーが
追加の努力なしにあなたの言っていることを理解することが指数関数的に難しくなります。
したがって、この単語
を間違ったピッチ アクセントで言い、この単語
を正しいピッチ アクセントで言い、発音が間違っているとします。
エラーが発生し、
この単語を間違った高さの
アクセント パターンと間違った
発音で発音する場合
、それは一種
のことで
あり、もはや単一の単語の問題ではなく
、連鎖する一連の間違いのようなものです。
あなたが思っている
以上に高低アクセントや発音の
間違いを犯している
かもしれませんが
、時間の経過とともにこれらのほとんどを解決できるでしょう。
時間の経過とともにではなく、遅かれ早かれそれを行うには、高低アクセントと発音を遅かれ早かれ勉強
するのは良いことです。
大丈夫だと思います。
最後の質問は
これらのピッチ アクセントのグラフィックスについて、何人かの
人々は
、それはフラットであると言うべきだと言いました。
あなたは、この開く単語は
多かれ少なかれフラットなパターンで設定されるべきだと言いますが
、このグラフィックでは低から高への上昇がある
ので、 フラットだと言います
が、実際にはグラフィックではフラットではありません
ここで何が起こっているのか これは
非常に非常に複雑なトピックです
が、物事を非常に簡単に要約
すると、日本語には異なるピッチアクセントパターンが存在し
、 このパターンではアクセントのないパターンの一種として知られています。
通常の速度では通常の速度で非常に高速
です。ネイティブ スピーカー
がこのパターンを持つ日本語の単語を言うとき、彼らは
多かれ少なかれフラットで言います。 のようにもう一度パターン
を言うだけ
で、画面にグラフィックを表示するつもりはあり
ませんが、ネイティブスピーカーに
同じパターンを
ゆっくりと
慎重に単独で言うように
頼むと、多くの場合、  t は通常
、ピッチをわずかに上げて言うので
、
低く始まると、ああ
、これは似たようなものと考えることができます。
この英語の単語をすばやく
言った
場合、私はほとんど正しいとは言えませんが、これをゆっくり
と言って 分離私はそれをリトルと言うでしょ
う真ん中
のtはtリトルと発音されますが、
すぐに言うと真ん中のt
はdリトルと呼ばれます
実際には肺胞タップであり、
おかしなことに日本語ではrの音です。
単語をゆっくり慎重に言うと、
通常の速度で発声する場合と、実際に
は
わずかに異なる発音になる
ことがあります。他のルールがあるため、通常はこのように単語を表示するのが
最善です
この低い発音で教えられている単語
については、
グラフィックがこのように見える理由
です。
彼は
低速で通常の速度
で最後に、多くの人
がこれらのネイティブ録音について尋ねました。彼ら
はどこでこれらを入手できるのかと言いました。ええと、私
はこれらの録音を作成するためにNHKアカデミーに行った訓練を受けたネイティブスピーカーの専門家を雇い
ます 私と
彼らは素晴らしいマイクを持って
いるので、それらはコンピューターで
生成されたものではなく、そのようなものです。それ
がその答えです。大丈夫なので、
始めなければなりませんが、このビデオ
がお役に立てば幸いです。あなたの将来の日本語に幸運を祈ります。
勉強して、またすぐにお会いし
ましょう